spahic s'entraîne le labrador est
dressée pour détecter les punaises de
lit elle est morte lézignan tojours donc
s'il ya des mots qui continue son chemin
s'ils trouvent des ventes pour trouver
une ou deux ça soit autant que pour
trouver des années dans cette salle
d'entraînement des capsules comme celle
ci qui contiennent des punaises de lit
sont cachés et un petit filet pour
qu'elle autorise passe et ils
s'habituent à ressentir à travers tout
simplement qu'à trouver les pneus
en fait ça proches n'avaient plus le
plus proche possible avec son museau est
vrai qu'il va donner le coin le plus
proche où elle a craqué de 10 20 ou
quelque chose comme ça pour aller plus
proche qui nous a dit ce qui n'est plus
le plus possible ce classique des kinés
plus proche possible
8 ça soit selon sébastien lemay il y en
a entre 5 et 6 chiens détecteurs de
punaises de lit au québec ils sont
appelés à travailler dans les résidences
privées mais aussi dans les
établissements comme les hôtels ont fait
les meubles et les moulures les limiers
sont donc ce qui est plus propice à
trouver c'est surtout par prévention que
les hôteliers font venir les chiens et
notamment après une période achalandée
comme le temps des fêtes où la saison
estivale sûr que les hôtels c'est plus
propre et sa soeur parce que il ya deux
mondes dîner now tout le temps fait que
c'est sûr que si quelqu'un en a mais il
peut en rester dans le dis si on met
deux valises par exemple sur les lieux à
ce moment là il ya des chances que si en
eau dans la chambre qui rentre dans les
valises qu'on ramène sur chez nous que
sinon c'est plus dans les blocs
appartements parce que ça se propage
plus vite
c'est sûr que les chiens sont en demande
va se terrer rapides très efficaces
c'est assez compliqué à éradiquer en
fait c'est un travail de minutie qu'il
faut faire c'est une bonne recherche
il faut enfin le but de l'opération ce
qui en reste plus pentue si en reste une
il s'agit d'une femelle enceinte depuis
le problème pour partir au bout de
quelques mois le chien dressé peut donc
agir là où l'oeil humain a ses limites
et pour l'animal il s'agit tout
simplement d'un jeu pour s'assurer que
le travail du chien est optimale ils
sont certifiés sur les vrais odeurs
chaque année ici milly richard à radio
canada sherbrooke